ohne direkt in die ukraine und zwar an
die front wo bild reporter paul
ronzheimer ist im don was direkt an der
kriegsfront vor zwei monaten war er auch
schon dort vor zweieinhalb monaten kurz
bevor der krieg begann und da hat der
ludmilla getroffen sie hat ihre heimat
erleben müssen die komplett zerstört
wurde heute hat er die allein stehende
ältere frauen noch einmal getroffen und
er wollte wissen wie es ihr nach mehr
als acht wochen krieg heute geht
paul ronzheimer trifft heute erneut
ludmilla in nach kiew ghana donets wir
wollen wissen wie es ihr geht doch dann
kommt
apa
der keller hier verbringt wird wieder
die meiste zeit nur im keller ist die
vor den bomben sicher so geht es jetzt
seit 65 kriegstagen paul ronzheimer war
einen tag vor kriegsbeginn schon einmal
hier hinter mir sie hat sich gerade in
ihren keller geflüchtet das ist wie ein
bunker für sie dann ist gerade wieder
heftigen artilleriebeschuss hier direkt
an ihrem haus die front die verläuft
sozusagen quer vor dem grundstück auf
der einen seite die ukrainische soldaten
auf der anderen seite separatisten heute
sehen wir die ergebnisse zerstörung und
verwüstung in lubmin us straße ist jedes
haus zerstört hier wohnt niemand mehr
sie sind entweder geflüchtet oder tod
vor zweieinhalb monaten waren wir das
letzte mal hier nah gfk im keller von
ludmilla die situation ist eine völlig
andere zwar gab es vorher schon krieg
aber jetzt ist es wirklich dramatisch
die häuser drum herum sind alle
beschädigt ludmilla sagt die einschläge
sind fünf bis sechsmal am tag so heftig
dass sie sich um ihre tiere klammert und
hinter den möbeln versteckt aber dennoch
sie will weiter nicht weg obwohl hier
kampfflugzeuge fliegen obwohl grad
obwohl artillerie eingesetzt wird und
obwohl fast alles um sie herum in dieser
straße zerstört es sagt sie ich will
hier nicht weg ich will in madagaskar
bleiben denn hier ist alles was sie hat
ihr hund to seek der schon zwei mal
angeschossen wurde ihre katzen ihre
hühner verlassen will und kann ludmilla
ihr zuhause nicht
ich werde die fk nicht verlassen niemand
braucht mich irgendwo ich verstehe die
jungen leute aber ich habe herzprobleme
einen hohen zuckerspiegel ich bin ein
kranker mensch
das essen ist knapp wie lange ludmilla
und ihre türe die situation durch halten
können weil sie nicht
wenn sie addiert kaum zügeln was ich
nicht was ich tun werde um ehrlich zu
sein trage ich immer etwas clooney den
bei mir wenn ich bemerke dass ich in
einer situation bin aus der es keinen
ausweg gibt oder ich werde verletzt oder
etwas anderes weil es keine hilfe gibt
dann trinke ich clown ideen und schlafe
ein
die zeit wird knapp mit jeder einzelnen
bombe die hier täglich vor ihrem haus
einschlägt schwindet für ludmilla und
ihre tiere die hoffnung den krieg zu
überleben
und wir sind direkt mit paul ronzheimer
verbunden der uns diese bilder geschickt
hat paule das ist am unter die haut
gegangen gerade als ludmilla gesagt hat
dass sie dann das medikament nimmt um
einzuschlafen
ja absolut omas und ludmilla seine frau
die ich nicht erst seit ein paar monaten
kenne sondern seit vier jahren also
immer wenn wir hier auch früher über den
krieg der sehr regional begrenzt war
damals noch berichtet haben haben wir
sie besucht wenn man mal etwas essen
mitgebracht medikamente haben wir schon
damals eine schwierige situation für sie
war aber so wie heute habe ich sie noch
nie erlebt wie sie dort saß und
angekündigt hat dass sie sich umbringen
würde wenn sozusagen
russische soldaten kämen in ihr haus und
ich habe dann immer wieder versucht
zusammen mit vadim unserem ukrainischen
kollegen sie davon zu überzeugen lasst
uns doch dir helfen hier rauszukommen
wir können dir helfen nach polen zu
gehen sogar nach deutschland oder nach
kiew zumindest oder irgendeinem dorf was
sie in der nähe ist und sie hat gesagt
nein ich will bleiben ihr geht ich
bleibe und dann am ende hat sie mich
umarmt und ich hatte meine schutzweste
natürlich die ganze zeit an und dann hat
sie zu mir gesagt bitte bitte verspricht
mir das hier immer eure schutzweste
tragt und euren helm tragen und dann
habe ich zu ihr gesagt aber du bist die
ganze zeit an der front du hast keine
schutzweste und dann hat sie gesagt ich
hoffe dass gott auf mich aufpasst
ja wie gesagt das geht unter die haut
paul ludmilla hat gesagt sie bleibt wie
ist es mit den anderen menschen dort in
dieser kriegsregion so nah die russen
dort ist das allgemein so dass die
menschen dort bleiben wollen
nein das ist nicht allgemein so in der
straße von ludmilla sind fast alle weg
du hast ja die häuser dort gesehen die
meisten auch zerstört werden mit dem
gouverneur dort sprechen könnte hat
gesagt die den großen bunkern der stadt
sind zweieinhalb tausend menschen wie
viele in der stadt geblieben sind ist
nicht so wenn auch klar tatsächlich ist
es aber so dass diese stadt gerade heute
sehr angegriffen wurde und zwar mit
russischen kampfjets mit artillerie mit
grad man dort durchfährt wir auch mit
unserem team es ist eine sehr
gefährliche situation und gleichzeitig
auch eine
geisterhaft unheimliche situation
jederzeit kann irgendwo etwas
explodieren und die strecke allein zur
ludmilla ist schon clips bedrohlich
haben auch gesehen und gehört in den
bildern die duh geschickt hast dass sie
auch nicht viel zu essen hat die
versorgungsprobleme wie können die
menschen sich dort überhaupt vernünftig
versorgen im moment wo bekommen sie
alles ja wie läuft das logistisch ab in
dieser kriegsregion
nun milliarde uns erzählt dass sie in
den vergangenen monat nur vier mal brot
bekommen hat weil sie dann raus gehen
konnte viele läden sind auch geschlossen
die meisten haben nicht auf und oft ist
es einfach zu gefährlich rauszugehen sie
werden versorgt teilweise von
freiwilligen wir haben natürlich heute
auch ludmilla einige typen mitgebracht
das was wir schleppen konnten also
sozusagen leute die dort wohnen die sie
kennt die versuchen zu helfen aber
tatsächlich ist natürlich das problem
auch der elektrizität des wassers seit
zwei tagen gibt es mal wieder
elektrizität aber eigentlich in seit
beginn des großen krieges sagte sie uns
ist die ganz häufig ausgefallen und die
große sorge eben wenn ab 11 körper lässt
so ein strategisch wichtiger ort ist
dass der eingekesselt werden könnte also
diese gefahr thomas über die wir am
anfang immer in kiew gesprochen hat die
ist jetzt hier im donbass akut nur dass
die ortsnamen die städtenamen nicht so
bekannt sind in vier wie kiew und dass
dort auch nicht würde maddie lenski oder
vitali klitschko wohnen sondern menschen
die man in deutschland vielleicht nicht
so kennt aber die genauso um ihr leben
bangen
nun ist es ja eine großoffensive gewesen
die angekündigt worden ist und es ist ja
diese verrücktheit der bilder man sieht
dann oft gar nicht so viel davon und
fragt sich
großoffensive ist das wirklich so was
von jets gesprochen die fliegen im
moment aber wir müssen wir uns das
vorstellen kommen dann in nächster zeit
die panzer eingerückt dort von
russischer seite aus wie wird diese
situation mit wird dieser krieg dort
direkt im donbass weitergehen
ja die großoffensive muss man sich vor
allem so vorstellen dass russland
versucht mit allem was sie haben auf
diese dörfer zu schießen mit artillerie
mit grad und sie versuchen es eben
anders zu machen als in kiew wo sie ja
sehr früh auch mit bodentruppen gekommen
sind wir dann unser die bilder wo
helikopter truppen nach kiew gebracht
haben die dann sehr schnell abgeschossen
wurden und panzer rund um tiere die dann
mit ja berlin oder mit
panzerabwehrwaffen attackiert wurden
genau das will man hier verhindert und
dafür ist auch die region besser händel
basis steppe ist es flach dh hier kommen
russlands waffen besser zur geltung und
hier kommt klar zur geltung dass der
ukraine eben diese schweren waffen über
die wir seit wochen und monaten ja
diskutieren noch fehlen insbesondere
artillerie um sich wirklich zu
verteidigen vor uns haben wir ganz
herzlichen dank und wenn du ludmilla
nochmal sie ist groß sie von uns hier
aus berlin danke